今天台灣股市又殺尾盤了
很多人覺得怎麼會這樣子
我今天一定要跟大家講三個重點
今天台灣股市的量能
只剩下6294億元
上禮拜7000億 7000初
我就說很慘了
以前1.5兆以上的成交量
現在給我腰斬
現在股市 股價還沒有變成4成
但是量能已經變成4成了
以前1.5兆 現在6000億
這種破底行情是似曾相識嗎
散戶不玩了怎麼辦
幸好哲哲的點閱率還是很高
我也愛你們啦
輝達漲價15% AI穩了嗎
這代表什麼意思
大漲特漲耶
還有奧特曼潑冷水 潑什麼冷水
ChatGPT的創辦人
引領這一波AI行情的
奧特曼說AI的進展比想像中慢
是哪一種進展
AI到底是多還是空
我今天一次講個夠
台股早盤表現不錯
一度漲超過百點
結果又翻黑
最後跌了461點
收跌在44762點
雖然今天台股下跌
而且量縮到近期低點6294億
但是投資長的股票還是照樣噴出去
投資長的環球晶
早盤直接衝上漲停
中美晶今天同樣強勢大漲
很多人一定想知道
為什麼投資長這麼神奇
可以預測環球晶接下來要漲價了
另外投資朋友們
看到大盤震盪這麼劇烈
都很好奇台股會不會再打第二隻腳
回測40000點
也好奇這週四凌晨
要公布的輝達最新財報
以及週五晚上即將展開的央行年會
導致台股受到牽連嗎
你想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
今天台灣股市大跌
但是我有股票漲停
台灣股市季線 你破啊
來打我啊
來啊 我跳進來 我又跳出去了
又跌破季線了怎麼辦
重點是量縮啦 散戶退潮了
只有我們的粉絲沒有退潮
沒有辦法
因為我們是全台灣
唯一百萬粉絲的分析師
不只百萬 我現在已經140萬了
有做股票的都認識我
我現在很緊張
我現在已經快變大明星了
我現在不論是穿什麼衣服
不是穿西裝
穿西裝當然認的出我來
不論我穿什麼衣服
不論我什麼髮型
不論我有沒有戴眼鏡
好多人認出我來
我很緊張你知不知道
可是問題是
這也代表哲哲
你們對哲哲的愛 的量能沒有退潮
但是台股的量能退潮怎麼辦啦
我告訴大家不用緊張
我要告訴大家
這個行情這樣跌很正常
為什麼說很正常
因為就沒量能怎麼衝上去是不是
來 等一下
我們來看一下國際的股市
國際 講話大舌頭
講話大舌頭先跟大家講
我現在AI用很多東西 來
等一下再跟你講
我用了AI哪些東西
韓國股市有沒有看到
現在看起來要打第二隻腳 是
今天又一度跌了3%
來 看一下
韓國股市 有看到嗎
最後跌了3.27%
日本股市也跌
所以台灣股市最後跌個1%還好
量能退縮啦 能怎麼辦
可是我們來看一下
看一下費半
費半跟那斯達克就像我講的
費半看起來離低檔
這一波的低檔還有一段距離
所以不用緊張
那斯達克也不用緊張
現在就是債券殖利率的問題
我相信美國財政部長
他出身華爾街的
索羅斯的徒弟
基本上不會有問題 好不好
所以他到時候
一定會做很多事情打壓債券
真的不行的話就無限購買
不然要怎麼辦 來
那斯達克
怎麼辦 只是說本來要縮表
看起來都很難 來
那斯達克看起來離底部
就是這邊底部
這邊破了
台灣股市就有機會跌破40000點
這邊破了就是這個地方
哲哲再買1億的台灣50有沒有
這邊 來
你已經這一個漲停板
你已經少賺到了
現在好不容易回檔了
你為什麼不買
你不用緊張 我問大家一件事情
你看上禮拜 航運股強啦
是不是 沒錯
我來看一下
航運股是萬海
2615萬海
航運股強講萬海
等到航運股真的要叫你買的時候
結果給你開高走低 是不是
航運股強講陽明
今天有點開高走低
航運股強才講他
我跟你講現在航運股跌了
長榮今天跌了
受不了才叫你買
我說這叫老投顧
投資朋友你要搞清楚
哲哲跟別人不同
我不會特別去攻擊某一個分析師
沒有意義
除非那個分析師攻擊我
那不好意思
我不得不迎戰
而且我迎戰的時候
花多少律師費我都不在乎
這個投顧界都知道事情
沒有辦法
這個我一定要捍衛我的名譽
投資上的名譽
來 我告訴大家
我不會特別針對誰
可是我要告訴你
一些老投顧做法我不會去做
股票強
我們摩爾投顧的分析師
都比較認真一點點啦
股票強
你有沒有發現到
不是股票強就有了嘛
那很多人之前有國巨的
有記憶體的
突然不當一回事的
或是真奇怪 南亞科漲講南亞科
是不是
晶豪科漲停講晶豪科
今天晶豪科創新高了
不是這回事嗎
現在股票的確很難做
所以你看到
我們今天的股票漲停板
就是屬於我們的
環球晶 有沒有看到
這就是我跟別人差別
在40000點的時候我親自掏腰包
掏1億買台灣50
讓大家不要緊張
我可以私底下買
我不用這樣東湊錢 西湊錢
還怕被你們笑
結果也不是
為什麼我的點閱那麼高
因為大家很信任我
大家知道我講話講在前面
大家知道我不是魔術師
不是Magician
變變變 變不見
變變變 變漲停
天天有漲停你還相信
不要傻了啦
越講越多漲停的
越不敢參加選股比賽
我們講的都是真的
這種行情那麼難做 怎麼可能
可是你看我的股票
環球晶之前700多塊
我沒有說過
Lily我有沒有說過
我說那時候700多塊的時候
778 是
然後那時候我的台灣50漲停
還有人笑我說
我的環球晶怎麼辦
我說我寧願買環球晶啊
是不是 沒錯
所以你看環球晶現在漲的還比較多
投資朋友
我寧願買環球晶啊
你看1010除以778
至少20%以上啊
1億我就賺2000萬
我願意當分析師
其實我少賺很多錢
大家真的要看一次珍惜一次
每一次我的解盤
你看這個股票今天又拉上漲停了
你看斗大的新聞都在講什麼
你們自己看一下
有誰比哲哲還認真
真的不是我要臭美
3年多首見矽晶圓要漲價10%
有沒有看到 有
3年多啦 為什麼
6吋 8吋 12吋
全部都漲
不像被動元件喔
被動元件有些標準品
其實還不一定有漲喔 是
不是喔
這才是可能真正的記憶體2.0
那現在分析師講被動元件什麼東西
講到500多塊
沒有像我有Guts丟進去買
400多塊叫你買國巨
漲價一成
疫情過後3年多首度大漲價
環球晶 台勝科 合晶
有沒有 有
我人很好啊
台勝科 台灣No.1啦
我還跟你講說我比較少解他
因為什麼
因為比較少人買 沒關係
我主要的跟你講環球晶跟中美晶
你是要我這樣的分析師
你看投信有沒有
我說投信偷吃我們豆腐
誰吃誰的我不知道啦
投信開始買有沒有看到 放大
投信開始買了
連續幾天開始買有沒有
真的耶
你要的是這樣的分析師
我不要去事後話 馬後炮
投信有沒有看我的節目
你覺得有可能沒有嗎
140萬裡面的粉絲
沒有基金經理人嗎
怎麼可能沒有
大家心照不宣
我選的股票有價有量
夠我塞得下牙縫 好不好
夠我塞得下肉
這是你要的分析師嘛
講到漲價
漲價為什麼漲價
我們先來看一下
你要懂邏輯
你才知道下個AI題材是什麼 來
半導體矽晶圓
三年以來首度全部上漲
有沒有看到 有
全系列同步調漲10%有沒有看到
下半年6吋 8吋 12吋
你看我們做的圖多好
為什麼你看不到
為什麼我做的AI圖
就是比一般其他投顧分析師好
我講的是事實 沒有辦法
寫得非常清楚
下半年漲價有沒有
你們自己看 為什麼漲價
因為很簡單 庫存調整改善
AI帶動先進製程
我再講一次喔
現在目前什麼
來 我們的邏輯
現在是因為先進製程缺貨了嘛 是
成熟製程也開始缺貨了
可是記憶體這一塊
本來沒有缺
就因為 這樣講好了
我問你一件事
什麼叫記憶體這一塊沒有缺
記憶體現在是不是缺貨 是
現在記憶體沒有缺貨
輪到我們等一下要跟你講的
輝達會大幅度漲價15%嗎
記憶體就是很缺
讓他予取予求
為什麼很缺 因為擴廠還沒完畢嘛
擴廠還沒開始
應該說擴廠還沒有正式成功嘛 對
等到記憶體擴廠的時候要怎麼樣
需要矽晶圓
最上游的矽晶圓材料
這時候就要環球晶了
我有沒有講這個邏輯
我跟你講這只是一開始的利多
沒關係 Lily沒關係
你今天很興奮 我覺得很好
我們這個尾音
差不多就好 沒關係 謝謝你
有沒有很興奮 有 對不對
有 好 來
AI帶動先進製程 供給端庫存調整
這些東西我都有跟大家講
環球晶 台勝科
現貨價 合約價通通在漲
產業鏈健康 他們自己說的
台勝科說新報價陸續生效
我再講一件事
現在只是先進製程
等到記憶體在擴產的時候
更需要他 漲翻天了
你看00981A賣掉又怎麼樣
我不在乎
之前賣幾百塊我不在乎
我做很長的
就像我講一句話 哲哲的名言
我看起來有那麼短嗎
你們都想歪了
看起來有那麼短嗎
是不是 你看這種爛行情
我還有股票可以漲停
你就知道哲哲多強
我再講一次
這種爛行情 股票就漲停了
我跟你講 我現在就是要買AI概念股
台灣股市能上漲就是AI概念股
不要什麼跑到化學 化工
什麼塑化啦
塑膠 你當我塑膠的
我沒有啦
航運股我也不打算買啦
這跟AI沒有關係啦
沒有很多關係啦 是不是 OK
不要念Lily 我不是念他
沒有念他 來
你看 Lily你有粉絲耶
沒有
來 5230人
週一症候群 多一點人吧
目前看起來有點短
你這樣說 來
南部 跟南部沒什麼關係
大家不要戰南北好不好
來 看到哲寶就興奮 很興奮
來吧 真愛
華新科還有救嗎
被動元件有救啦
是不是 洗板仔
對 不要太多洗板的
好不好 我就說塑膠的
相關的我不想講好不好
來 聯電今天一度漲停不算救嗎
什麼意思 聯電也不錯
成熟製程就會缺嘛 都AI相關的
所以環球晶剛漲而已
3532台勝科剛漲而已
合晶 6182剛漲而已好不好
這些股票到時候漲了
你就不要
你要去想想看
現在是散戶退潮 量能退潮
等到散戶回來
你知道什麼叫恐怖
來 我們今天要求不多
你不要說7000億
助理 這等於今年以來
4月7號以來的最低量對不對
你幫我看一下
是4月7號以來
等於現在台灣股市
是45000點左右對不對 對
結果成交量大概跟31000的時候比
這不對 你知道為什麼不對嗎
因為我股價漲50%
我加權指數漲50%
從31000漲到45000
不是差不多50%嗎 是
我股價漲50% 我什麼都不要動
我成交量應該要多50%
沒有錯吧 沒錯
所以我現在換句話說
現在這個成交量是非常萎靡的耶
可是就是因為萎靡
你要參加我的行列
你至少要看我的節目
想到我的名言了沒
我叫你ALL IN就ALL IN
我叫你重壓就重壓
不要跟你開玩笑
記得一件事好不好
一定要加哲哲的行列
可是加哲哲的行列你不要加錯 來
我很佩服詐騙集團的創意啦
然後助理說他會搞混
我說我也很佩服你
這樣也會搞混 來
有沒有看到
譬如說這是我的留言
謝謝你的愛對不對
但是你的照片可以換帥一點
有沒有看到 有
然後直接寫
要進我的群組
添加我管理LINE
這個一看就知道貼圖啦 你知道嗎
可能我如果是白色背景
他覺得沒什麼
看就知道貼圖啦 好不好
我不會主動叫你
添加我管理LINE
我不會什麼事叫你添加管理LINE
我沒有那麼缺業績好不好 OK嗎
我的LINE就是這些為主好不好
來看一下
LINE @s178
有沒有看到
好不好 沒有別的LINE
除非你參加我的會員以後
我們有那種VIP的
那也不是 那也是用這個講話的
不是用截圖好不好
投資朋友 截圖是截圖知道嗎
你知道現在可以改圖嗎
你知道嗎 你知道昨天還有個新聞啦
助理傳給我新聞啦
你知道現在不斷地改圖 改影音多少
越來越符合我說的未來
我再講一件事
我叫各位說不要當演員
沒有跟你開玩笑
家裡有帥哥美女的
不要當演員
當歌手還有得救
當演員現在快沒救 為什麼
現在中國有看到什麼
很多的明星根本都失業了
為什麼 因為都看AI影片
老人家越來越看AI影片
我聽到現在老人家
那個AI影片很好看
我之前看那個什麼地獄判官
我之前看一下 AI的影片
我之前說真強者假廢物
我跟你講那個影片
只會越來越厲害而已
連Netflix可能都會受影響
所以現在你有Netflix可能要走掉
我沒騙你 你可能要走掉
因為除非Netflix
也要跑AI這一塊啦
跑AI影片這一塊
你只要記得眼睛注目的地方
就是可以賺錢的地方
中國大陸好恐怖
好恐怖 進展好快
我要告訴大家 這個不是說
我不是要跟大家講政治
我講的是實話
所以AI影片很恐怖
這個都是在取代
這些取代就會有人投資
為什麼不投資
是不是 以後發現AI影片OK了
我可以省很多人力
所以我就說以後會很多人失業
相信我 以後會很多人失業
你要記得我這一句話
最好就是投資AI相關的
看我的節目
看我的節目你會謝謝我
我不是來賺錢的
我不是說我每天收會員
我不屑做這個事
我希望幫助你
助理傳那個相關新聞
什麼30%
然後最近什麼AI的影片
那個新聞你給我就好 不用做圖了
如果能做圖真的最好
開機率
就是我們本來以前12個影片
可能10部講好的影片要開機
要開電影 拍電影 拍劇情
10部裡面 大概可以開個9部 10部
現在講好10部要開了
不了了之
10部裡面只有3部
慘了啦 這麼少
真的很慘 很恐怖
就是AI
所以AI影音都可以
所以AI也可以修改截圖好不好
我不會叫你加
這個用我的名義
那是截圖 不代表我的名義
很聰明 知道說這個用真的
他以前是用別的
用真的 模仿我講的話
之前還模仿我的聲音什麼的
是不是 沒關係
魔高一尺 道高一丈好不好
記得一件事 OK嗎
好不好 這個跟大家講
應該這樣講
也不能講
我怕有講錯 我還是修正我話
你加入我這個LINE以後對不對
我還是會跟你講說我助理的群組
但是要你加入我的LINE啦
不是什麼在網路上宣傳啦
你聽懂嗎
要加入正確的
對 因為我們公司還是有業務助理
會加入他個人私人LINE
但是不是用圖片 OK嗎
我怕你沒聽懂
反正不要用圖片對啦
沒有圖片這一回事啦
好不好 一定是我本人親自講的
圖片這個都可以改的
這個也可以改s178 179
s168168
s88888是不是
你聽得懂嗎 對
這都可以改的好不好
可是不會主動在網路上
叫你加入我LINE 怎麼樣
你看很聰明
現在變成加什麼
我說沒有什麼社群
他說叫我加LINE
沒有截圖這件事 好不好 OK
不要看截圖的對話好不好
我不會主動叫你加入我的LINE
不會在網路上主動叫你加入我的LINE
一定是你跟我對話的時候才有可能
記得 我不會
因為我沒那麼缺業績 不好意思
來 我們看一下大家
還有什麼 AI電影珍珠港事變
有嗎 一堆AI電影是不是
來 瘋了吧
大帥哥 哲哲寶貝
文曄還有救嗎
等一下我有機會看一下
又有人被洗版了是不是啦 一直被洗版
來 不要 這個太長了
這種不要洗版洗成這樣子 好不好 來
哲哲寶貝好帥
為什麼華邦電總是過不去
看一下
因為華邦電我有稍微講過
華邦電沒有過不去
你們跌一點點就受不了
你們這麼短的不要做了 好不好
真的不要
股市沒有一定 好不好
記得股市沒有一定 股市有賺有賠
股市沒有一定
其實我這幾天滿開心的
因為我很多的訴訟案件 看起來
我覺得啦
都有機會沈冤得雪
因為之前不是告一個
不知名的媒體嗎 168嗎 對
賠我錢嘛 是不是
因為我都知道
我那時候看 我講秘密
其實有時候我都知道
對方的弱點在哪邊
他有好多的那個誹謗的前科
我發現 奇怪
怎麼沒有人告他民事
大家都告他誹謗前科
我覺得他都不怕
我一告他民事的時候
我就知道這是他的痛點了
你懂不懂 是
因為我要查封他的財產
沒有什麼錢
那你攻擊我根本就是為了錢嘛
我說這是事實
我已經跟你講了
哲哲最厲害的就是毅力
跟我知道對方的優缺點是什麼
就是這樣子
接下來還有一些對某個分析師
該做什麼事我該做什麼事
我為什麼要講這種事 我也不知道
好無聊 有時候
因為講一講還是有時候生氣一點點
對不起 我不應該講那無聊的事情
來 你看
吳慷仁的基金經紀人
這個很大牌的經紀人
你看一下這個東西
Lily為什麼剛才突然講到這個東西
你也不知道
突然跳過了
沒關係 人生跳過
當我碎念一下 當做廣告好不好
因為每次 總要講給同業聽
不然每次同業都覺得可以挑戰郭哲榮
賺自己的 好不好
攻擊我不會增加你的業績 來
吳慷仁 而且我說老實話
我真的覺得我有把投顧業
投顧的餅做大了
所以你們攻擊我要幹嘛
以前投顧餅沒那麼大
真的啦 對啊
來 吳慷仁經紀人
嘆沒有戲可以拍
開機率只剩去年30%
有沒有看到 有
很慘耶 吳慷仁經紀人很有名喔
他不有名
吳慷仁怎麼從台灣跑到中國去
是不是
他很有名喔
你知道嗎
而且都是那種影后等級
很多人都沒有工作 有沒有看到
他直接說很多人都沒有工作
現在演員都沒有工作啊
為什麼 都看AI啊
我有沒有跟你講
你看這是今天才出來的新聞
8月22號
我跟你講 我再講一件事情
你們現在做客服人員的
拜託你一件事
第一件事情 趕快準備換工作
真的我是為你們好
第二件事情 買AI股票
買不懂的你就買ETF
我跟你講
你相信我 大家做朋友啦
我告訴你 你以後會愛我啦
做客服我跟你講
以後我認為80%啦
以上的客服人員
全部都會被克服
這個工作會被克服
全部被取代
我上次有跟你講用這個東西
不需要再試驗一次吧
我叫他當中國信託的客服人員也可以
當那個也可以 你知道嗎
所以這都是我給你的預測
你知道嗎
我很多的預測是很恐怖
你看我今天凌晨
12點的時候發文章
天啊 傳出最新消息
輝達下一代伺服器要漲價15%
有沒有看到 有
沒錯吧 凌晨喔
這是我的
那你們看一下
這是我的預測能力
記得一件事 來
不要看截圖的
什麼添加我管理LINE
我不會主動在網路上
跟你講這些東西
我要的是在我自己的
這個LINE裡面
知道嗎 好 來
不會在網路上亂貼圖
我還沒講完話
來 這不是重點
來 最新消息
輝達要漲價有沒有看到
凌晨有沒有看到
有看到嗎
來 頭版新聞是什麼
輝達伺服器喊漲
工商時報報導
你們要看報紙啦
不看報紙至少要看我的節目
經濟日報喊漲 有沒有
頭版新聞都是
可是我永遠領先
我永遠領先群雄
我永遠領先很多的媒體
那你就是要這樣的分析師嘛
所以記憶體也好
被動元件我高檔出 低檔進也好
還有現在最強的矽晶圓漲價
我都是領先群雄
然後聯發科我說胡扯
什麼1萬塊麥格理
我也是為你們好
鐵沙掌
今天有點痛 不知道為什麼
我為你們好啊
你告訴我
看我的節目像看什麼連續劇一樣
是不是
你不覺得很恐怖嗎
我喜歡當預言家
我是不是說以後
我再講一次
你們不要當
真的駕駛人員也是一樣
以後真的很多人都會失業
你們相信我講的事情
那為什麼現在沒失業 好不好
我再跟你講一個東西
要先講這個還先講股票
我告訴你
為什麼現在很多人還沒失業
我先看你們的回應
再埋個梗 好不好
哲神我服了 是啊
你相信我 現在你要當分析師
要當那個演員 要趕快轉行
除非你超級帥 你毅力很強
要毅力很強 不然不行
我覺得編劇的比較厲害
中國AI都免費怎麼賺錢
但是你覺得
AI怎麼免費的
以後可不可以插廣告
我問你 臉書都免費的
人家不是賺幾百億 賺幾千億
你懂嗎 OK嗎 來
量縮通常是相對低點嗎
其實量縮不重要
我只是嚇你的而已 好不好
量縮比較痛苦的是我們
沒量 我們的業績
我們的營收就會下滑
分析師也是
還有那個券商也是 好不好 OK嗎
漲和跌都是準 預言家
智原等一下再講一下 好不好
有空的話
合晶還是環球晶 哲哲寶貝
你叫我寶貝 我就要出賣我自己嗎
當然不是 你要參加會員
問我合晶跟環球晶 是不是 來
好啦 你們都說哲哲寶貝
6700 趕快多一點
請問又有錢了可以ALL IN嗎
可以 盡量ALL IN
我就說了
我連演員會失業我都跟你講了
我是演員嗎 不是
要演員 我也是財經喜劇
財經喜劇幽默演員
優質演員
不是 我不是演員
好啦 我們是分析師
很多人說哲哲 財經綜藝節目
來啦 所以我說演員
真的會失業
我跟你講 為什麼很多人還沒失業
這個講到重點了
奧特曼最新的對話
今天傳出來的
你相信我 明天會有很多人
明天會有很多財經網紅
開始解讀我這一塊
看了哲哲節目 這一段有重要
奧特曼潑冷水
AI顛覆比想像慢
因為經濟有巨大慣性
有沒有看到 為什麼
他的意思是說技術已經到位了
就是我再講一件事
因為我不要再用一次
我們有試過吧 有
我叫他模仿中國信託客服
他馬上告訴你
你為什麼要剪卡
我說我要剪卡 為什麼
會測試我的資料
還會什麼東西
那技術到位了
只要用一個API把它串接
專門針對中華電信客服
或者是中國信託
這個一定可以
只是第一個
有些老闆不一定那麼快
那麼聰明 這麼勤勞
或下面的員工覺得慣性
為什麼 我幹嘛那麼快被人家取代
是不是 吃力不討好
所以技術已經到位
但真正改變會比多數人想像的慢
你知道嗎 這沒什麼不好
可是當他改變的時候
當他真的改變的時候
你會發現到
一夕之間全部改變了
當他改變的時候
你發現不好意思
你們全部客服人員 全部失業
我好希望我的節目裡面
真的有客服人員
因為我而轉行
他知道要趕快去考什麼證照
或來摩爾上班都可以
我是說真的
我說真的 或去別家上班
來 奧特曼說過
AI技術像高鐵有沒有看到
企業導入卻像塞在高速公路 為什麼
因為採購習慣
譬如說我今天
我要中華
我是金融業 我有受什麼
金管會的法規
我不是說導入一個客服就可以
你懂不懂
你懂嗎 我不是導入客服
那我的資料存取在哪邊
我這一端還是別人那一端
好 如果是我這一端 那好啦
可是我的技術裡面
我一定有一問一答
那我有身分證字號
我身分證字號叫Fxxxx 你知道嗎
不是罵髒話
我是真的F開頭好不好
這個是F
不是 我差點講出來
我的身分證字號了 你懂不懂
我是說我有身分證字號
我的年紀 你知道嗎
那這個東西
這個資料存取在哪邊
Gemini嗎 ChatGPT嗎
Gemini現在還沒有
還沒有那種客服的語音技術
ChatGPT有
那不能存在他那邊
因為有法規規定
所以法規很麻煩 有些法規很麻煩
那沒辦法
金管會也是為了大家著想
你這些資訊
客戶的信用卡資訊可以存嗎
我每次在講卡號怎麼辦
我怎麼可以存在
ChatGPT這邊裡面
我要存在銀行這邊
這些資料怎麼辦
那我要串接
這要測試 組織流程
法規與人類行為改變慢
很多人 我跟你講
連我喔 我每天都跟我們公司的主管講
你要用AI
他們都好慢
我就每天教他們
我今天怎麼問問題
比如說我今天要去日本
我跟你講
我的行程你可以看到 我很佩服他
我很會問問題
你要會從他裡面問問題
最難的是問問題
可是我很會問問題
你要去溝通 去問問題
三個答案
我寫個文章 有時候
不好意思 我有時候寫文章
不到3分鐘
我不想跟你講哪些文章
因為我只要大綱
然後我用講話講的
我現在連打字都不打了
我大舌頭 他都聽得懂
很恐怖 你們現在會用AI的人
真的是以一擋百
我其實我現在很會用AI
你知道嗎
我現在 其實我也不一定
我說老實話
我們公司的設計人員
可能聽了會難過
我也不一定要設計人員
我知道怎麼樣
可以跟他們圖做得一樣
我知道怎麼樣寫文章
我可以寫得很快
我是說真的
這都是我要不要去
有時候我去做 去跟他們講
有時候不如我自己做比較快
所以我告訴大家
人類行為改變慢
因為不是每個人像我這樣
這麼變態會要求自己
這沒有辦法
可是他說也是因為這樣子的話
本來是2到3年一次性爆發
反而有5到10年
更長的資本支出循環
大家慢慢的 為什麼
因為最怕的是行情一次走完
我全部人都失業了
那個駕駛人員也失業了
我那個什麼客服人員也失業了
很多公司的內部行政
那些流程都可以簡短了
都失業了
失業率大幅上揚會怎麼樣
會抵制AI 會抵制喔
我光一些水跟電就會抵制AI
那抵制AI以後
我本來採購量
我假設我的採購量
要100台AI伺服器
我可能只能採購到30台伺服器
因為你害我失業啊
政府為了選票一定慢慢來
可是因為讓你有時間調節
你們要失業了
反而讓AI的資本支出慢慢來
反而讓那個景氣慢慢的往上
這就是我要的10萬點行情啊
這是奧特曼講的
你不覺得跟我的想法不謀而合嗎
原本市場想像是這樣子 很快
現在長期產業升級 有上有下
技術都已經到位了
我告訴你
你問真的懂邏輯好的人
哪邊技術不到位
客服人員哪邊技術不到位
只剩下法規還有人類的習慣而已
怕大家不敢相信這邊那麼快
我也不懂啊
那時候明明
那時候我就覺得一年內有疫苗
怎麼樣大家看不懂我看的未來
我也不懂啊 我說口罩會缺貨啊
你們那時候有沒有印象
我說口罩會缺貨
開始要搶口罩
大家覺得口罩這種普通東西 爛東西
怎麼會缺貨
品質這麼普通的東西幹嘛缺貨
缺貨啊 我也不懂啊
台灣那時候沒有疫情
我說遲早會有疫情
疫苗要先打
我怎麼知道到最後
等到要打的時候大家排隊啊
還要利用關說才能打疫苗啊
人類就是這麼動作慢
而你看我的節目
我不喜歡只當分析師
我喜歡當預言家
我的感受是
你們覺得我好強 我好變態
所以我告訴大家
你要看的是我的頭腦
你們不要每次看我的肉體
我指的部位很奇怪
看我的肉體
我昨天還去重訓 深蹲
為了你們壓力很大
開玩笑的啦
享受這些啦
這樣懂不懂我的意思
所以相對安全啦 你知道嗎
OK嗎
他講的東西
我們現在主要是看輝達財報
漲價15%了
你覺得輝達財報會不會上調
當然預測會上調嘛
你懂我的意思吧 是不是
OK嗎 來
聽了哲哲
投資長關於AI的想法
作為公司可以前進的方向
提出了提案
建了屬於公司的AI
來 放大
真的是屬於大大提升部門的效率
我告訴你
所有公司的效率
都可以提高至少一倍以上
只要你們肯用AI
我告訴你
真的都可以裁減員工 要不要而已
像我們公司也可以
說老實話也可以
只是我要不要
有部分的公司的領導階層或老闆
像我這樣
我就覺得沒有必要
身為一個領導階層
我覺得沒有必要
一定要馬上就要裁員
我覺得我想的是這些
有些比較狠心的人
是覺得他不知道怎麼做
我是覺得沒有必要 OK
你說阿嘉有沒有看到
他老婆以前熬夜看陸劇
現在熬夜看AI劇
越來越多人
我問你 你只看AI劇
你不看陸劇
陸劇的演員不是就失業 是
駕駛人員也是一樣
你每個都要自己駕車不是一樣
客服人員不是一樣
設計人員也是一樣
會大幅度失業
可是也因為以前會預期奧特曼
奧特曼是ChatGPT的創辦人
你知道嗎
ChatGPT是
是因為他才2023年
我才預測AI股漲一整年
那時候我去財經節目
大型財經節目
我跟他講的時候
大家睜大眼說 你在說什麼
我在想你們在想什麼
你懂不懂
他是這樣的創辦人
正式引領AI 引爆行情的人
他最新的預測
而且我跟你講 我再講一個秘密
因為我Gemini
ChatGPT Claude我都用過
我覺得最好用的
除非是專案工作才用Claude
Claude你會想跟他吵架
講話很嗆
你看我三個都用過
最好用的是
現在目前為止最好用ChatGPT
我的行程安排 很多
我不想再講
因為有些是商業秘密
我可以做很多事情
我講了 因為別家投顧都會看我的節目
我就不講了 來
運動員也沒價值了
大陸機器人運動會
百米紀錄打破了人類世界紀錄
I don't think so
運動員還是有價值
你照這樣講
以後開飛機跟運動員比賽就好了
那不一樣 好不好
那我以後找一個投籃高手機器人
NBA就會失業嗎
這個邏輯不對
運動員就是觀賞用的 觀賞比賽用
AI的出現比工業革命更恐怖 好不好
新低量必有新低價
不一定 有人說低量出飆股
技術到位 人們還不知道怎麼運用
就要串聯嘛
因為每一家公司的流程不一樣好不好
00981A再漲不上去
也可以換0050
或是漲上去換 好不好
Gemini不只延遲更新
有時候問一問 他說
我只是什麼 我只會文字什麼
他就是記憶體不夠
所以慢慢漲OK
外資157億是賣還是買
外資賣157億 來
哲哲怎麼看整天喊空的
我不需要 你不要引蛇出洞
你不要引誘我去講那些做空
因為台灣做空的分析師沒幾位
沒什麼 有些人就喜歡做空
這沒什麼 只是股市做多比做空簡單
股市做多獲勝的機率
比做空獲勝的機率來得高
因為做空是這樣子
跌很快 你懂不懂
有時候跌的話是幾千點
但是跌很快就跌完了 OK嗎
自從加入哲哲會員
讓我大賺3000萬
謝謝你 不只一位好不好 來
我跟大家講 來
新興航運怎麼看
我說航運股我沒有想要買
謝小不要一直
你們現在好恐怖
你們現在留言好恐怖 好不好
環球晶可以再買嗎
環球晶我覺得可以再買
環球晶再跌到1000元以下 好不好
群聯再跌到2000元以下都可以買
我怕群聯跌不到2000元
你們自己不理我
這邊是2000元
有沒有看到 這是2000元
所以這邊不要
我怕不會再來了 今天2135
環球晶可不可以買
1000元以下可以買
你有沒有想過一個分析師
賺了170%都沒走
我記得沒有錯
我記得好像 我看一下
我們看欣興
你看欣興我賺161%
我記得沒錯 欣興賺161%
你看我賣在300多塊
我快氣死了 後來1000塊
可是你看環球晶我賺170%
賺得比欣興還多
我沒走耶
我記得是賺170%
反正有超過150%
因為那時候是什麼
因為那時候環球晶1600我沒走
天啊 好像快200%了
天啊 我1600沒走
那他股價跌到778
你還買得比我便宜
你現在要謝天謝地
這一次股災讓你買很低
這一次股災讓哲哲1億就馬上賺1000萬
你要謝天謝地 投資朋友
可以靠腦袋賺錢了 各位
AI會顛覆很多人的生命
會豐富很多人的人生
也會造成很多人不幸
你要把你的不幸變成幸
看我的節目改變你的人生
很多人就是不願意去改變
鐵達尼號要下沉的時候
還覺得OK 沒關係
不是
你知道韓國有個船難 你知道嗎
那時候好像有學生
船難你知道 有學生
就是怎麼樣
就是畢業旅行還是出去玩 你知道嗎
我不知道你有沒有聽過這個事情 有
你知道最後會出事那群學生
是最聽話的
因為老師叫他待在船艙裡面
如果他們沒有待在船艙裡面
在甲板上早就沒問題了
你聽得懂嗎
所以有時候你該改變要改變
投資朋友 該改變要改變
我是說真的
該改變 你覺得哲哲講的對不對
你不會多用AI喔
真的是哲哲可以以一當百
我沒騙你 我一個人做事效率
現在可以贏100個人
而且又快又好
所以你們要學習AI 好不好
以後家教行業也會開始失業了
我是認真講的
你們不要做家教 補習班
真的 不要去做家教 補習班
頂多有人會賣題庫吧
你相信我 會很難賺啦
再加上台灣少子化會很難賺
趕快轉行
我希望你們看得到我看到的未來
真的 我是說真的
當然我知道
有些人就不相信我講的未來
我能說什麼
反正沒關係 久了就知道
這些東西我基本上
我很有信心 好不好
比預設股價
我覺得更有信心
當然什麼事不會說百分之百
我只是跟你講
Wait and see
你到時候看到哲哲就是預告
不然你看 講話很臭屁
哲哲講話很臭屁
為什麼100多萬粉絲
很多人是從以前 1 20年前
開始看我的節目的
看很久 證明我的清白
證明我的能力 你懂嗎
這個不多說了
我們來看一下
2303聯電 聯電今天快拉漲停
那是因為之前沒有漲
漲不多 人家以為要打第二隻腳
所以我跟你講
你們不要想這第二隻腳會不會破底
理論上不會破底的好不好
快8月了 快年底了
萬聖節 聖誕節
好不好 OK嗎
這個都有了 好不好
還有你看一下
來 還有這個股票我們看一下
5347世界先進
沒有理由聯電拉起來
世界先進不拉起來 今天變跌
世界先進就是漲很慢
很氣人 好不好
還有我要說什麼
那個群聯 群聯你該買就買
群聯EPS漂亮 好不好
你看好像3006
晶豪科也在創新高
群聯為什麼不能漲
2408南亞科也在拉了
為什麼不行
不要開玩笑 好不好
這個要把握住 好不好
那我們來順便看一下
還有微星就不用講了
微星要死不活的
因為微星的重點是
因為他先創新高就被人家狙擊了
現在不要追高
記得股價拉回就買
你看環球晶不就是最好的代表嗎
股價拉回就買
再跟我講一次
股價拉回就買 知道嗎
3374精材
這裡面中實戶要不要買而已
你看今天看起來
要拉起來又殺下去了
精材底下 之前不是有利空嗎
這個利空大概是
我們看一下幾元
記得 290元這附近好不好
應該會有支撐 好不好
所以基本上也不會打到250這邊
好不好 OK
這樣懂嗎 記得這件事好不好
記得 好不好 這個跟大家
我的鴻海負9%
你有些股票如果很弱
我的鴻海有些會員也有被套
如果說你是會員
哲哲 我有點被套了
我今年的績效
我認為我還是分析師界裡面最好的
當然從5月 幾月
應該是從7月以後
績效變得比較普通
我記得好像5 6月還說我
有沒印象 我說每一檔股票每個會員都賺錢
沒錯
每一次進出都賺錢 是
這個跟大家講 好不好
那個所以有些股票說
要不要換股票
可以 可是你來找我比較好
參加我的會員比較好
那個謝小 不要這麼誇張
這個洗板的 我不歡迎洗板的
洗板的就暫時不要留言 好不好
助理記得看一下
換什麼工作才不會被AI
很簡單喔
譬如說像分析師
你要當分析師趕快來 好不好 OK嗎
要當分析師趕快來
摩爾應該是全投顧
可以最多自培分析師
就是訓練分析師
到那個千萬名師以上 最多位的
而且有些不只千萬
講太多我怕你又不信
所以沒必要講
這個業界都知道的事情 好不好
就是自己訓練分析師
有些就是說你不用很多天分
也可以當分析師
以前是這樣 要有天分才能當分析師
天分很多種
來 會員多少錢
這個你自己來問一下 好不好
哲哲0050賣了嗎
你在說什麼 我不會賣
我連美債這個垃圾都沒賣
這個跟大家講
什麼人 有看到摩爾在徵人
什麼人不會被裁 很簡單啊
就是會用AI的人
什麼事都會用AI
你們以後謝謝我
不論你們以後會不會看我的節目
以後你們都會謝謝我
哲哲你預告在前面
然後還有什麼人不會被AI
醫生也不會啊 為什麼
要有替死鬼
最後要有人做決定
分析師也是一樣
AI不會跟你講說一定要買這檔股票
你懂不懂
不會跟你講進出點位啦 你懂不懂
它不會幫你負責任
就是要有人負責任的職位
你懂不懂 要有人做最後決策的
你懂不懂 OK嗎
像駕駛員不在了 你做決策啊
你自己當替死鬼 好不好
出事了你要負責任 好不好
所以會叫你方向盤
不能離開手 一樣啊
就是找不到替死鬼的那個行業
那就需要AI
醫生這個行業找不到替死鬼
你不能說機器人幫你開刀
所以馬斯克說會取代醫生 不行啊
還是要醫生當替死鬼
講替死鬼三個字好像很不尊重人家
就真的是替死鬼
分析師也是一樣
我們要幫你下建議
要我們這個替死鬼幫你處理
因為AI不可能當替死鬼
這樣懂不懂
我講的是真的
要有人負責任啦
不要講替死鬼 要有人負責任
我叫ChatGPT學哲神選股都教不來
要是教得來我就不用混了
來 這個跟大家講
貴司不要會員賠錢的時候
拍短影音開跑車出去炫富
應該沒有吧 是誰
我會建議他
你們看到有時候股市不好的時候
我自己手錶都不見了
應該沒有 助理提醒我一下
提醒老師一下
把這張圖截圖一下
我們應該沒有會開跑車出去炫富
應該沒有 來
這個嚴禁禁止
我會跟他們講一下
應該不會啦
應該是以前的影片 大家不好意思
我幫他們跟你說聲不好意思
國巨腿軟怎麼辦
你們這叫腿軟啊
你們是沒看過股災
你們是沒看過再狠一點
給你再回測476元是不是
龍巖不會被AI淘汰 沒錯 好啦
醫院大概只有院長和專科主任
不會啦 都很缺 好不好
護理師也很缺
分析師我只看哲哲 謝謝大家
分析台指期
我們看一下台指期
現在幾分了 45了
我們看台指期最新的
現在跌了32點
不用看了 量就縮
我跟你講行情總是在半信半疑中成長
沒有跌怎麼會有我的那個
一下子就台股漲停板
我跟你講 我講一句難聽的好不好
我還巴不得他跌破4萬點
我真的巴不得台灣股市跌破4萬點
把這一群人嚇死了
把這一群就是在做短期價差的人
全部嚇死
我巴不得
可是我認為他就是不會啊
跌破4萬點
我不敢說百分之百
可是他就是不會跌破
既然不會跌破4萬點
你在想什麼 拉回就買了
我跟你講 你們會後悔
那個助理
因為最近有參加滿多新會員的
提醒我開始要給他們重倉買入了
你知道嗎 助理
提醒我明天要買 把他買光光
他不會跌破了啦
量縮是一回事好不好
量縮是一回事 這邊不會跌破
我管他季不季線
我有沒有說我這次不管季線 有
因為我就說會磨很久
很多人都看季線
這次會磨很久
這邊不會跌破
既然這邊不會跌破
就不要想是跌到這邊 還是跌到這邊
還是拉起來
不要想那麼多好不好 OK嗎
哲哲一切的一切預告在前面好不好
我們最後來看一下 來
還沒說中美晶
中美晶有什麼好講的
之前不是說什麼味之素嗎
那個什麼缺上游ABF載板材料
他更多利多啊
他唯一的問題就是他沒有那麼純
矽晶圓沒那麼純
他有多晶矽的題材
太陽能題材會拖累他
就這樣子而已
遲早200元以上
要買純的 你還不如買台勝科
環球晶是最猛的 記得這件事
你不要覺得他現在貴
等到以後2000塊 3000塊
你就知道什麼叫貴了 好不好
不要覺得貴嘛
2000塊 3000塊不是重點
就是你買的金額除以他的股數
就好啦 你懂不懂
1000塊 100萬
100萬除1000塊 是不是
就是這麼簡單嘛 就除以多少嘛
假設一張
假設我環球晶1000塊 是不是
我1萬塊就可以買10股
就這麼簡單 哪有那麼難
我買不起 我不能買零股嗎
我記得好像以前零股
好像是9點5分 10分後交易嘛
不好意思喔 我不會去買零股啦
可是現在開始 好像接下來開始
要9點就交易了
9點交易零股了
我覺得 我懇求主管機關
要增加台灣成交量很簡單
你知道怎麼樣嗎
很快的讓台灣股市像美國股市一樣
我問大家一件事
大家覺得台積電很貴
如果以後不是用一張
一張是大概多少錢
237萬嘛對不對 是
我用一股來算
一股才2375元 對
你懂嗎 我用一張來算
是不是237萬嘛
是不是 沒錯吧
可是不是啊
如果我用一股的話就2375元
這樣聽起來還好
所以台積電很多人就想買了
你只是換個觀念而已
朝四暮三 朝三暮四一樣啊
這個系統很快就可以改了啦
我真的懇求主管機關
我記得一件事情
我希望5年內 甚至可能更快
主管機關想通了這一回事
證交所想通了這件事
我跟你講台股成交量還會再出來
因為全民都怎麼樣
不是全民皆兵 全民都股民
知道嗎 我講這個東西
最後幾分鐘
9點10分開始零股交易 沒有啊
之後要變成9點
買零股可以啦
NVIDIA如果財報好
沒有符合預期 資金要跑到航運
不會 我覺得他這次不錯
因為華爾街去更新他的財報
不會這麼快
他沒有想過要漲價15%
你知道嗎
現在記憶體佔AI伺服器也很高喔
佔AI伺服器
有時候一台AI伺服器要1億台幣
他佔到 對啊 伺服器就是這麼貴
他佔到15% 1000多萬台幣
1500萬
他現在漲價15%
等於我管你漲不漲價啦
你漲一倍我也不怕啦
我還多賺錢
輝達 全部你們
管你被動元件要漲 台積電要漲
Whatever 你有沒有看到
而且你看他這次游刃有餘
昨天還買個包子你知道嗎
還買個肉粽
來個2小時 很多人說來會見台積電
2個小時不可能
跟人家吃飯不可能2小時
這樣很不尊重人家啦
純粹來吃東西
就像有些人去日本吃個拉麵就回去了
一樣的意思啦
我都知道他們在想什麼啦
所以你看
台灣股市你自己不找我要找誰
哪個分析師像我
不好意思 真的不是Magician
不是什麼航運股強就突然講航運了
那記憶體呢 被動元件呢
每次都有漲停的股票你相信
不是嘛
你看我的環球晶 我跌照講
我就是這麼有Guts的分析師
好不好 有些股票跌照講嘛
是不是 今天有人說智原
智原怎麼看
智原沒怎麼看啊
智原等到真的主流
跑到ASIC題材
這還要一陣子 沒辦法
他是AI的邊緣了啦
但是總比航運股來得好一點點
航運股是AI的邊緣的邊緣啦
你知道嗎 這個跟大家講
你不能說要運送AI伺服器
然後貨櫃
那個沒有差 營收沒有差多少
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
所以我們今天真的很開心
最後幾分鐘
50了 我要結束了
這都實在績效好不好
你看幾十% 幾百%的有沒有看到
100% 200%
加起來恐不恐怖
今年績效真的很好
環球晶有沒有看到
已經大賺88%了
有沒有看到 持續看好他
而且一堆人
是買在6 700元好不好
你想想看你要怎樣的分析師
想清楚了 想明白了
我們今天粉絲人數好多
你看留言都是如雪片般飛來
所以想清楚了
來 全台灣唯一100萬粉絲
不是100萬喔
不只唯一100萬
也是唯一140萬粉絲的分析師
最紅的就是哲哲
如果你不認識哲哲是誰
你一定是股市菜鳥
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
最近好多人參加我的會員
我明天還要一次
用力買個夠
我們努力一次賺個夠
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
我愛你們 Byebye